horizon zero dawn probably what a lot of
you came here for today it's what I came
here for today nothing against buzzer
but it's not it's no horizon yeah cuz it
got a 5 out of 10 on gamespot.com
horizon zero dawn got a nine out of 10
I don't know that than Peter Brown right
here yeah Pete we don't want to
reiterate your review too much but okay
sum it up I feel like they feel like
there's some stuff I wasn't able to get
through my review because there's a lot
to talk about in this game okay so I
played a lot of open-world games over
the past couple years and that includes
the likes of Xenoblade Chronicles Bennet
your solid 5 fallout 4 whatever this is
the first game that makes the action so
immediate and satisfying and throughout
the game that is what sort of drive
drives you to continue exploring the
world at least for me like at no point
did I ever grow tired of the combat and
that isn't that's partially because a
Lloyd the character controls so well but
also because she has a lot of different
weapons and the enemies are so great and
they have sort of an answer for
everything you throw at them so that's
like the one constant in this game that
that is always true and the second one
is the world is just beautiful to look
at the game guerrilla games knows what
they're doing their engine is amazing
and this is evidence of that
and so beyond that what you have is an
open-world game kind of like something
like Far Cry series I don't have a lot
of experience with but you kept telling
me like oh it sounds like far
structurally it feels like a Far Cry
open-world like cascading structure once
you unlock this outpost and then you get
this kind of side quest you're hunting
to upgrade your capacity for these
things right so yeah you've seen the
action but definitely those overall
structure and systems that play yeah
crafting is huge resource gathering is
huge and sort of working towards being
able to carry more and do more with what
you carry and then on top of that
there's a story that maybe doesn't start
out so wonderful well actually the
beginning is great the middle part is a
bit dull mm-hmm
but by the end it sort of goes into
areas that were hinted at at the
beginning of the game and it's like nice
to see them trade the tribal stuff for
like okay what's the deal with this
world why is this world like this
because it's this interesting mix of as
you can see like wilderness but then
also crazy technology and it's a it's a
marriage that is also represented in a
lloyd because you know she is
essentially an outcast from this tribe
as a young child and this is all the
beginning of the game she finds a device
that essentially lets her tap into
technology which no one else around her
has done or currently does comes into
focus yeah yeah I found her whether the
voice acting or the character animation
the character animation this game are
kind of weird sometimes like they skirt
the uncanny valley a little too much for
me yeah but I found her to be more
interesting of a character when she was
younger
well I've only played his her for like
two hours right now I liked her when she
was younger I thought the way they
characterized her as a child was so true
to how children are and I was so charmed
by it
she's like repeating lines that she
hears and repeating the things people
say to her and it was just it seemed
very real to me
sure um but I I think her motivations
are like pretty well-developed
um at least in the beginning to like get
you going and get you engrossed so yeah
and and I would love to spoil these
things but I can't so you know what I
can say though is that by the end of the
game at least the third act it is it is
so steeped in a Louis story the story of
the world that whereas yes I agree with
you her character kind of falls off
after the intro section the game almost
kind of does it on purpose to let the
world and like the tribal stuff come
into play to make you feel like okay I
understand what's happening in the
present day but then the end of it is
all about history and stuff like that
and stuff Eloy learns and her character
certainly comes around in a very
meaningful way for me and that's
probably a good segue because it's kept
you keep talking about the world in the
post apocalypse that's what I want to
talk about for this segment is
specifically how guerilla games the
Amsterdam based developer has kind of
crafted this how do I say unique because
the other people have done this but it's
crafted this rain the slew of
post-apocalyptic games we have this is
kind of a novel take on the post
apocalypse where I think they call it
the post post apocalypse yeah post post
so it's like a thousand years after
whatever event it's a thousand years
from now and just I just have you know
like not just dealt with and accepted
whatever it was whatever apocalypse came
about but they've adapted like back to
tribal warfare and politics they
actually have no idea why the world is
the way it is around them and accepted
it that just is how things are now and
right
machines sell put their own terms for
things you know their furtive things
based on the metal places yeah how it
makes sense you know the old ones
referring to us yeah yeah it's just how
it makes sense to them at their point in
time it's not only us it's an advanced
form of us from what I've gathered right
like the focus thing is kind of yeah so
technically the year I don't know if I
can spoil the year it's not exactly a
thousand years from today I think the a
loading screen says that they actually
give you a certain year that it's like a
thousand years from okay but it's
certainly yes an advanced form of us so
I do like P you said one of your
favorite things about the game was that
it this cool blend of futuristic tech
but also just like Stone Age tools and
like a really overgrown wilderness that
you're exploring it's cool juxtaposition
you'll be hunting like a boar
at one point and then you'll be hunting
this sawtooth Sabretooth machine it's a
really cool dichotomy between the two
Kali I think you and I have played about
the same amount of time maybe like four
or five hours issues yeah what is your
take on this world I guess are you
interested in it you want to keep
exploring it are you more interested in
the action of the game um I mean it's a
I think they feed into each other pretty
well like you said going from like you
have to hunt mammals for crafting right
so you're going from hunting mammals to
hunting a machine to get the tools to in
turn do something else and in that sense
like I wanted to learn more about the
world like I'm so invested in finding
out what happened to you know our world
to us you know get the set up for this
that you know I I want to do the
grinding I want to get into the action
and get the tools I need to keep
exploring um so I think it does a really
good job of that and I also think I like
I at first when I first heard about this
game was first announced I was really
worried about like oh I'm gonna feel so
underpowered with a friggin arrow
against a machine but it doesn't feel
like that and I think it horizon
balances that really well also like uh
like Pete said like you are always given
the information tools you need to take
something down it's a matter of
execution yeah
yeah and break that execution that
relies on you know you having to run and
dodge and roll out of harm's way okay
and managing a bunch of different
weapons like you'll have a slingshot
you'll have you know a few types of bows
to fire different types of arrows and
you're juggling all of this on the fly
and the game does a really good job of
allowing you to do this by using a
weapon wheel and when you're selecting
with the right stick time will slow down
but you can still run dodge and jump as
a Loy yeah yeah so you're still in the
action while you're choosing your new
weapon on top of that you can craft
while in that weapon wheel yeah it's so
smart so you can do all of this in the
middle of combat so it's this execution
both in the physicality of reacting to
an enemy and managing all of your stuff
at the same time to be an efficient yeah
you know person and then so if you see
this blowing bit right here
Eloy can use your focus to focus on an
enemy obviously and then get sort of
like where their weak points are and
those elements will stay highlighted for
a period of time you can knock those off
which will have different effects on
enemies some will have like a fuel
canister hit it with fire it'll explode
and that'll kill other nearby enemies or
set those enemies ablaze creating a
chain reaction mm-hmm or you can knock
off a piece of armor make them
vulnerable in that one spot or knock off
one of their weapons pick it up yourself
and use it against the monster yeah this
is that all of these options could take
place in a single minute of combat or
only one or two of them could take place
in a single encounter but they're all
good no matter how many you're juggling
it's yeah
that's totally what kept me going was
feeling like I had this powerful sort of
toolset and was kind of up to my
imagination and skill to make the most
of it yes some people are calling out
saying it's like Far Cry primal in a way
and I actually get that reference
because you are doing something similar
in Far Cry primal you're meeting the
tribes which also at the four hours I'm
in the inner tribe politics and kind of
cultural relations makes me think of Far
Cry primal and of course Far Cry primal
uses that you know that new open world
that you soft establish with Far Cry 3
or Far Cry 2 I guess we can go back
farther that kind of you know you unlock
this outpost and that leads three more
people that can give you quests and they
lead to like four more fetch quests and
it's really engaging kind of a cascading
like Waterfall structure of quests that
I really like
then horizon introduces more on like the
world building side of things that I
felt Far Cry primal did my chief Lord of
this game right now outside of the
action that you guys are talking about
and using the tools like using these
primitive tools to take down these
futuristic machines then vice versa and
kind of using the machines later on the
game to help you against them which I'm
just getting into now and I'm finding
pretty exciting to get these new tools I
really like the fact that I'm actually
invested in these audio logs and coming
across from the old world but like from
us yeah usually in a game I was telling
you this morning Pete like I'm I think
there's so many games out now especially
open-world games that I don't take as
much time as I would like to to get into
the lore in the backstory and like the
audio logs of a world but I like it here
because everything you're seeing in you
know engaging with is the the weird
world the weird part it's not it you're
learning the backstory in the lore of
that fantastical world in front of you
but then the audio logs are from a time
that we're familiar with or at least
like relatively we're like they're you
know at humans so when I get it it's
like grounding it and like bringing some
recognition to this world and I really
really like that I don't know if you've
had any experience with that in terms of
the world building this yeah a little
bit of the audio logs I really like that
I can continue to explore and just kind
of listen at my leisure and I can stop
and start it and I I normally when I
play an open-world game I like try to
explore every corner and it takes me
forever to finish but this one I'm I'm
just so invested in figuring it out
because they did like you said they do
ground it in like oh they're talking
about sort of technology that were you
know 20 30 years out from so it's it
seems realistic and plausible and when
you're hearing the audio like there's a
moment at the very beginning when you're
still playing as child
Eloy where she like sees a dad wishing
his son happy birthday and like that
sort of thing we're like oh he has to
tell it communicate with his kid because
he's doing whatever he is and then I was
wondering like why is he there what is
he doing like I just think it's it's
really smart in in that it gives you
sort of like breadcrumbs yeah at the
start and then I'm like I could not wait
to get to the point where I could start
exploring the metal world
and your imagination was kind of like
runs with these guys you know and it's
it's cool to see how the game at least
from my perspective like fulfilled the
things I thought I saw coming and then
also times didn't and it wasn't because
like I was wrong it was like I felt like
the game knew what it was trying to set
up but then you know the developers are
like we're gonna we're gonna surprise
you by you know bait and switch yeah
cool yeah I think I had a little bit of
it spoiled for me but not enough that I
don't care about what's going on because
I really AM invested in this story like
I said I think the voice acting is hit
or miss I guess that's just the case and
yeah especially when you're meeting so
many NPCs but yeah for all intensive
purposes this is a really cool take on
like an open-world I really love coming
across I think I'm like in the desert
region now or near it and then because
you know like we've seen this taiga
mountainous area throughout since it was
revealed what to e3s ago mm-hmm
we've seen that but then of course you
go these snowy areas you go to desert I
think it's like a more jungle area from
what I hear it's a pretty varied world I
don't think they ever I mean maybe it's
a spoiler I don't think they ever
particularly say it's at this part of
Earth they don't they do I don't okay
well either way it's it's it seems like
a microcosm of Earth right just
different biomes and I don't know maybe
you go to more urban environments I
don't know that's a spoiler but when you
do come across like vestigial traces of
our world it's really cool the metal
places they call it but they're
forbidden and then you know you get the
sense that they're forbidden because the
tribes don't want us to have that power
at least that's my understanding of it
now like three hours into the game so
it's super interesting I get a sense of
weird reference I get a sense of the SHA
melange the village where they like
don't let them go out oh yeah they're
like making up these myths this folklore
to prevent them from wandering too far
out of mound reach it doesn't go to the
same logical yeah they're like the
boundary Brody doesn't trip into a spike
pit wearing a red cloak both mouth sorry
I just blow that movie but yes I can see
the parallels there like it is I think
the Nora tribe is sort of fearful of
Technology because they've seen evidence
of what it can do to people yeah and so
they want to basically like prevent that
from happening again okay and I'm
interested in seeing how these different
tribes interact uh there's like the one
that lives in Meridian Africa it's
called
de carga the Caracara I'm just starting
to meet a few of them but yeah I don't
know
that weird guy hits on you yeah they do
with a mutton chop oh yeah what I was so
uncomfortable I think he's it was either
son Prince they keep talking about was
that no he was just some dudes I'm like
no he's not even a car Jay he he sort of
becomes your your buddy over time and I
think at one point he even apologizes
like good for having hit on you but yeah
I mean like it was supposed to be
uncomfortable so I thought that was
effective I he was drunk
- I think that oh really I think that
was the deal I think he's always drunk
actually I said he needed a second the
dude who came brought him with him for a
drinking a second stuff yeah it's a it's
you're at a party for context I would
like to say I think some of the tribal
lore is a little bit of a shortcut like
the you know the matriarch sand the all
mother and it I know in post
post-apocalypse apocalypses website
Apokolips sees does that count for the
word or no anyway I know you know like
the traces of the old worlds and all the
progress we've made are usually wiped
out in a post post apocalypse so it's
like okay of course we're gonna start
from kind of square one or square zero
but I do think it's a it's a little bit
of a convenient not a cop-out but I was
kind of at the very beginning I'm like
oh okay a matriarchy okay
oh you know they worship the goddess all
right and it just it it seemed like they
were they had gone too far back into
like oh we're tribes and we make up
these myths to explain the world when
like boy has this focus and she just
gets ever she's like oh right so it's
why I like almost immediately that
tribal stuff just feels long in the
tooth especially like a you know it I
played the game for about 60 hours and
I'd say about 20 hours in the story
starts to really focus outside of the
tribal stuff mm-hmm so thankful for it
because it really just it doesn't it
doesn't add up to a lot you sort of like
there is a conflict that arises you
understand it there's not like the
moving pieces within it they're not that
great yeah I also a little wary of it
just because I'm not sure what current
worlds inspiration they have
the tribes it's it feels like they're
wearing and like native
american-inspired garb I mean yeah
matriarchy is like a very I mean where
I'm from in the Northeast the Iroquois
tribes are all like it was matron Rachel
and also creation story sounds sort of
similar - yeah I mean they didn't have a
super AI there's a lot of stuff that is
that seems very reminiscent of Native
American culture I'm one hand the game
is like really good at putting you know
females at the front of the game not
just alloy but other characters that are
females are really strong and that's
nice to see and you also see a lot of
like people of color as well
this is great definitely like I'd say
the vast majority in this game are but
then a law is cast as this white girl
like wearing all this tribal stuff I
mean like it's one step in the right
direction we're back we were thought
about this yesterday not to nitpick but
would there even be many white people
this far in the future like was there a
National Geographic thing about how like
that they're white it's all right I I
feel weird talking about this is like
three Irish as hell white people but it
did give me pause
I don't absolutely it's not just being
said it's not just looking for things to
be sensitive about this is blatant I
would love for somebody who's more well
versed in the topic than I to give their
take on it like I would love to read
that or sure that like tweet at me I
would love to know more but yes so I was
I was a little hesitant about it I'm
like okay they're wearing like a lot of
beads and some people have dreads and
they're that's okay
that's the thing hail or doesn't have
dreads by that she looks like she has
dreads that's talking to somebody about
this and like this white girl with red
hair and dreads and I'm like no matter
he doesn't dress up and when I don't
blow my hairdryer and straighten it
that's how my hair looks so well yeah
yeah oh yeah really no I wish I could do
dreadlocks but yeah the and I find it
interesting her name is almost alloy a
mixture of metals so we'll see where
that goes story wise I don't know I'm
not smiling
yeah maybe she really is just a machine
I have no idea anyway cool so yeah those
we just want to talk about the world
building itself of the game because it
is kind of a pretty novel way of taking
on the post post apocalypse
and that's a good segue into our next
section Oh before I go on twitch user
Midlake as well as a few other people
are asking what the games released it is
correct me if I'm wrong it's February
28th on ps4 yes so a week from yesterday
yes so next Tuesday yes this coming
Tuesday it's way easier way to say
February 28th yes let us know what you
think about the world-building hopefully
we'll have more to talk about next week
when you play it again because we always
want to have you involved we don't want
to be just talking about these things to
you want to hear your feedback so let us
know on Twitter Pete Brown kelipah laggy
magma Hardy will respond to you
[Music]